et sans détour laurent wauquiez répond
ce soir à nos questions bonsoir sans
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
ump vous êtes surtout pour aujourd'hui
en tout cas à l'auteur de ce rapport
vous préconisez notamment parce que vous
apportez des solutions possibles la
création de maisons de la santé
étudiants directement implanté sur sur
les campus
mais alors pourquoi avoir laissé faute
de moyens fermer tous ses centres
mutualistes qui existait ça fait à peu
près 15 ans qui a une politique derrière
toutes tendances confondues qui a
consisté à vider progressivement les
services de médecine préventive
universitaire moi il ya un exemple qui
au cours de la mission m'a beaucoup
frappé c'est une jeune étudiante qui
avait le cancer qui est venu nous voir
pendant la mission et qui nous a dit si
je suis encore là aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'il y avait un de ses services
de médecine préventive qui ont détecté
mon cancer suffisamment tôt et qui m'ont
permis de le soigner et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est vraiment arrivé à
un stade où il faut tirer une sonnette
d'alarmé forte juste un chiffre en
france on a un médecin pour 10 mille
étudiants en norvège et dans l'ensemble
des pays nordiques
un médecin pour 4000 étudiants donc
l'idée du rapport c'est à dire on a
besoin d'une maison de la santé
étudiante justement mais pourquoi ces
centres mutualistes on l'a vu dans ce
sujet qui est vraiment les étudiants où
je repose ma question ont fermé les uns
après les autres et que le gouvernement
les a laissés fermé mais gouvernement
parce que là dessus il faut être très
clair il s'agit pas d'en faire un sujet
de polémique de dire c'est depuis trois
ans que ça s'est installée c'est une
tendance longue depuis 15 ans quel est
le problème
en france on a tendance à considérer
qu'en matière d'enseignement supérieur
on s'occupe pas des conditions de vie
étudiantes des aspects concrets de la
vie des étudiants beaucoup manière aussi
sur sur les lieux où habitent les
les étudiants vous proposait également
un bilan santé
alors une fois que le diagnostic est
fait c'est ça le bilan santé d'aller
voir un dentiste d'aller voir un
ophtalmo
quid des soins parce qu'il faut bien les
payer les soins après oui bien sûr c'est
pour ça que le problème fondamental
c'est l'accès à la complémentaire
étudiante aujourd'hui un étudiant au
moment où il décide ou non de se prendre
une complémentaire il le fait à la
rentrée
or la rentrée c'est le moment où il faut
acheter ses bouquins paient les frais
payé les frais d'inscription
universitaires éventuellement s'acheter
une caution pour s'installer dans un
petit appartement ou un petit studio
donc ils n'achètent pas à 58 et donc la
complémentaire c'est la dernière roue du
carrosse or nous ce qu'on a ciblé sur la
mission c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui que 80
% d'étudiants qui ont une complémentaire
contrairement à la moyenne nationale qui
est de 92% donc un vrai vide
et comme vous l'avez montré dans votre
sujet du coup quand il faut aller chose
soit chez l'opticien soit faire des
soins bucco-dentaires bandits non j'ai
pas les moyens donc vous proposer un
chèque santé
oui à hauteur de 100 euros à peu près
quand on sait que les premiers prix un
des mutuelles pour les étudiants c'est à
peu près 80 euros 180 180 euros comment
comme qui va avoir accès à ce chèque
santé quelles vont être les critères
pour pour l'obtenir
alors le chèque santé déjà expérimenté
sur deux départements c'est d'ailleurs
intéressant un gauche le nord et un de
droite qui et les alpes-maritimes et
l'idée c'est de donner ce chèque santé à
tous les étudiants parce qu'un des
points très important c'est que les
étudiants aujourd'hui qui sont en
situation de difficulté sont plus les
étudiants qui appartiennent à la classe
moyenne modestes ceux qui sont non
boursiers et qui n'ont pas accès à des
dispositifs d'être dernière question une
réaction plutôt à vos propositions
l'unef à l'un des principaux syndicats
étudiants demandent l'ouverture rapide
de concertation la définition d'un
calendrier pour que ce rapport
aboutissent de manière urgente
alors que votre précédent rapport déjà
sur les étudiants n'avaient abouti à
rien fin de citation
ce que je réponds c'est que c'est un peu
schématique mais de la part de l'ined je
le comprends aussi chacun dans sa
posture
le précédent rapport il a abouti à une
simplification importante des bourses
il a abouti à la mise en place d'une
allocation aline qui aide les étudiants
qui s'installe dans un logement
il n'a pas abouti à tout ce que je
souhaitais et j'espère bien que ça va
continuer à se dérouler notamment sur
ses aides aux classes moyennes
donc là tout de suite maintenant voir
rapport il va dire que la cour
maintenant ce que je veux c'est avoir un
le fractionnement des paiements de
complémentaire pas tout payer à la
rentrée
deux des vraies campagnes de promo de
prévention notamment sur l'alcool sur
les campus universitaires et 3 la mise
en place progressive de maison de la
santé étudiante
merci beaucoup laurent wauquiez d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci